[Musique]
il y a un an avant recommence laventure
qui fait l'objet de cette enquête
voilà les seules images que pouvait
offrir le plateau de pardailhan à 40 km
de béziers
ce spectacle qui est aujourd'hui celui
de 350 finale français il a un nom dans
les dossiers d administration du
ministère
on l'appelle le drame des villages
abandonnés l'an dernier rien ne
distingue et pardailhan le village qui
porte le nom même du plateau d autres
qui mouraient lentement entre le
vignoble et la mer c'était un beau
village encore habitable peut-être déjà
en ruine par endroits monsieur quand il
le menuisier et le seul artisan vivant
il doit aller chercher à béziers sa
clientèle au bistrot tabac qui fut un
des deux restaurants du pays
il attend parfois le dimanche monsieur
ligne aux anciens gardes champêtres et
monsieur romual le garde chasse du
chaton on parle des banques et du
dimanche autre front monsieur là dès le
propriétaire a pris sa retraite sur
place dans sa propre maison
mais le secret du destin de pardailhan
ce n'est pas du côté des fantômes du
passé et même entre les tempes paisible
du cimetière qu'on le trouve comme dans
toutes les communes de france
il est inscrit ici sur la pierre du
monument aux morts de 1918
ce sont ces absents qui font le vide
depuis 40 ans dans les villages et les
hameaux
et puis un jour ça recommence et non pas
la guerre mais la vie 80 personnes
venaient de s'installer à pardailhan 80
parisien pour tenter une expérience
unique en france
établir ici une communauté agricole
comme on en trouve en israël à cause du
modèle peut-être leur histoire se
raconte comme une parabole de la ville
vivent tous dans le même arrondissement
de paris le 11e il son tourneur sur
métaux ébéniste mécanicien fondeur
cherono chef d'equipe l'un d'eux vincent
thibout a passé un an dans un kibboutz
une ferme collective en israël ce qu'il
a vu là bas il raconte à ses parents ses
amis
c'est la révélation d'une autre vie
comment chacun sait décider comment
qu'ils ont quitté leurs quartiers nos
maisons leur métier vous le saurez ils
nous l'ont dit en mettant leurs biens en
commun ils trouvent à louer ses 300
hectares de terres abandonnées faire
revivre un terreau abandonné voilà ce
qu'ils ont fait écrire dès les premiers
jours
sur le papier à lettres à en-tête la
communauté nous vivons pour quelque
chose
un idéalisme c'est de faire revivre le
caillou sur lequel vous est posée si
nous allons planter des tomates à côté
de jérusalem entre les pierres ma foi on
peut très bien de faire de cette terre
en friche un chant qui sera très beau à
voir et je crois même autre chose c'est
que pour ces quelques trois cent
cinquante trois villages qui sont
abandonnés c'est la seule méthode pour
les faire revivre
il est évident que si un paysan arriver
ici et sol un bien se casse la figure
alors que nous-mêmes va toutes nos
difficultés
ma foi nous arrivons un résultat une
mystique de la terre peut-être et de la
vie communautaire mais aussi des
tracteurs dernier modèle en israël dont
il s'inspire on ne joue pas non plus à
retourner au moyen-âge ici d'ailleurs
tout le monde est admis juifs
catholiques et non croyants
pour le reste il respecter les principes
patrimoine commun pas de salaire chacun
perçoit directement et en nature
ce dont il a besoin pour vivre il n'y a
pas d'argent individuelle non absolument
pas même pas d'argent de poche enfin non
et en étant là que je viens de vous dire
de chacun selon ses capacités à chacun
son nom sur chaque paquet et bien vous
avez à ce moment là un responsable n'est
ce pas un économat notre économiste
n'est pas
que c'est toi tu t'occupes de cette
chose la disposition des cigarettes
rallier le ciel pour le travail lui-même
comment ça se passe et bien pour le
travail intérieur nous avons désigné des
responsables fabrique le plus difficile
ça a été de former ces gens qui
n'étaient pas du tout adaptée à ses tous
ces métiers sont nouveaux alors nous
avons dû former des tractoriste la
dirigeante acteurs pour un tracteur il
faut un mois un mois un mois et demi
quand ils arrivent au printemps 1960
avec femme et enfants tout est affaire
est d'abord réaménagé l'école
il n'en reste que deux sur le plateau
dans les classes du kibboutz on
accueille les enfants d'un mauvoisin
menacé d'école buissonnière forcé ils
font tous les matins 7 km en vélo moteur
pour assister aux leçons d'yves thibout
28 ans promu maître d'école par
autorisation de l'inspecteur d'académie
ses enfants et ceux ci qu'en gardant la
neustrie mène la vie de la communauté
telle qu'on la pratique en israël c'est
à dire qu'ils vivent entre eux au lieu
de vivre auprès de leur part même les
tout petits on ne les ramènent pas chez
eux le soir alors que les vents ne voit
jamais
oui des fois pour la bonne raison qu'ils
ont une re soir toujours une fois par
semaine il faut une maison le dimanche
on dimanche toute la journée
et puis ensuite toutes les semaines et
les maires qui passent la nuit à la dure
serait cette villa trouveront naturel
bien sûr s'ils brandissent tissi mais
qu'en pensent les autres ceux qui ont 16
ou 17 ans qui ont connu avant l'arrivée
au kibboutz une enfance normale
nous leur avons rendu visite ils ont un
dortoir où ils couchent à 2 parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez de lits avec une étagère
pour suspendre leurs effets et la pièce
attenante où nous les avons retrouvés il
ne danse pas ils ne vont plus au cinéma
ils sont d'une tranquillité parfaite
parfaite et un peu inquiétante quand
même si vous vouliez un soir descendre
samedi soir vous avez voiture si vous
pourriez le faire bien sûr mac a demandé
aux responsables
on n'avait pas envie non on va faire
faire un bridge ici ou jouer à plusieurs
jeux des garçons très sage aux sages
n'exagérons rien oui d'ailleurs nage
carte ici on a tous les jeux qu'on veut
ici alors vous mettez comme ça devant la
cheminée ou à table ou alors elle prend
un livre aux lilas où on peut lire dans
le livre vous discutez où on discute de
quoi sport ce qu'on a fait en journée ou
sur un 10 1 livre par exemple qu'on a vu
dans la semaine en hausse comme ça dans
le temps ce soir là vous coucher à 2
linge de lit ça vous gêne pas ça on en
dire mais tu ne vous êtes jamais seul
quoi finalement non on n'en jamais
jamais moi non plus
le moyen pour ça donne des idées c'est
jamais bon réveil à 5h ou 6h avec le
soleil sauf le dimanche qui est libre et
s'ils se retrouvent le dimanche matin
précisément à cette porte vers 10 heures
ce n'est pas pour assister ensemble à
une messe ou incultes mais plutôt à une
sorte de conseil de famille hebdomadaire
dans cette salle de réunion tendue de
matière plastique bleu comme l'école ou
l'agneau serait ont commenté des
problèmes religieux ou sociaux aussi
bien que l'avenir de la communauté que
l'on entreprenne de refaire une grange
ou de défricher une nouvelle terre ou
encore de juger d'une fois de commise
c'est ici que cela se passe devant tous
entre tous une des premières décisions
prises a été la construction de la
cuisine une cuisine énorme fête pour 80
personnes puissent comprend les repent
comme on l'a terminé au mois de mai en
septembre en huit jours ils font ce
poulailler modèle bâti sur les pierres
et des cailloux arrache au terrain en
octobre l'atelier mécanique mis au point
depuis l'été comment ça fonctionne et on
a obtenu une commande portemanteau pour
une fabrique de béziers
depuis le mois d'août les machines à
coudre de l'atelier de madame vergne à
paris ont été transportés ici en
confection des robes de chambres de luxe
pour les clientes de paris on s'en doute
les difficultés ne manquent pas il faut
être maçon charpentier laboureur
affronter le premier hiver faire face
aux problèmes financiers devant le
dernier carré des anciens ennemis qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils fuient ce qu'ils
appellent les fadas de paris ce qui leur
permet de tenir depuis dix mois
c'est peut-être ceux ci un coup de hache
c'est clair on voit ce qu'on fait manier
une scie un tracteur c'est clair dans
tous les propos que vous allez entendre
cette idée c'est le dénominateur commun
le bien commun ils ont l'impression
d'avoir retrouvé quelque chose là la
possession de leur travail
pour eux l'essentiel c'est ça ce qu'ils
font
le présent les projets le passé il en
parle avec détachement comme si cela ne
les concernait plus
j'ai rencontré dans leur nouvelle
habitation un jeune couple
ils ont honte un lit de tabourets comme
table de chevet une commode des murs nus
laurent comment êtes vous installé à
paris eh ben on était installés très
très bien salée gentiment main c'était
très petit le maître d'une pièce de 3 m
sur 3 m en un divan un divan une table
des chaises un buffet
qu'est ce qu'il y avait sur le buffet
des bougeoirs moderne
c'est un joli buffet oui vernis les
bougeoirs et et comment vous jouez vous
aimez cette pièce où coule oui je me
plaisais vous êtes heureux à vis de la
communauté me plaît beaucoup et la vie
de paris enfermé tout seul les sorties
la vie et paris avait aucun et voudront
up
il ya aussi un changement énorme paris
j'étais chez renault je travaillais je
faisais son empreinte du matin ici c'est
la vie naturelle je conduit un tracteur
la vie auchan et à l'air et à tout ce
bling je suis libre ils ont une façon de
parler de l'air vicié des grandes villes
dont on sent bien qu'elle ait moins
hygiénique que moral est ce que vous
faisiez à paris me se faire acheter
travailler comme artisan
monteur en tricot avec ma femme et puis
mes enfants pourraient vous êtes partis
de paris ah bah ça c'est pour fuir un
peu les les incommodités de la vie
parisienne
le bruit l'énervement et touche qui peut
être dans une ville lorsque l'on est
nombreux voilà me faire ça vous plaît la
vie ici oui ça me plaît beaucoup car si
chacun est au service de chacun un jour
où les blanchisseuses de lendemains
couturière troisième jour à la cuisine
j'ai fait un peu tous les services et
processus
c'est un système qui pour moi très bon
parce que surtout si l'on est nombreux
ça soulage beaucoup au point de vue
travail monsieur robert qu'est ce que
vous faisiez à paris goethe électricien
j'avais un petit commerce dans le 20e
arrondissement artisanale d'électricité
alors qu'à vous quand vous êtes venus
ici qu'est ce qu'il est devenu ce
commerce je leur ai vendu et j'ai fourni
les fonds à la communauté de pardailhan
vous deviez garder absolument rien c'est
un cas particulier
non tout le monde en a fait autant
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont donnée les autres
selon leurs moyens qui disposa chez eux
chacun vendu son mobilier son logement
ou les petites de souvenirs qu'ils
avaient personnellement l'âme nicole
vous êtes content d'être ici
pourquoi chez moi à paris j'étais je
venais me marier je suis habitué d'une
grande famille et j'aime le monde autour
de moi je ne pourrais pas vivre cette gt
tour chez mes parents
alors quand on m'a parlé de cette
communauté j'ai tout de suite été séduit
monsieur camille vous aussi vous
habitiez paris vous aviez un bon métier
pourquoi êtes vous parti
franchement au départ je n'étais pas
emballé du tout malgré mon métier était
très dur le fonderie vous savez la
grosse chaleur et ainsi de suite
il va prédominer une petite réflexion je
suis venu avec les autres étaient
maintenant vous avez j'en suis fort
content et vous monsieur paul
ah bah moi je vous dirais que c'est
plutôt sauté sur l'occasion parce que
j'ai déjà subi un peu cette vie
communautaire en tant que prisonnier et
malgré tout que dans ces tristes moments
mais j'ai trouvé les grandes joies que
je retrouve dans un sens ici vous l'avez
jamais eu envie de partir
j'en ai eu l'idée surtout ma femme qui a
eu une difficulté à s'adapter à cette
vie communautaire et qu'elle est partie
j'ai eu le désir de partir j'ai réfléchi
le plus longtemps possible
j'ai résisté et c'est ma femme qui est
revenue d'elle-même sans lui écrire sans
lui téléphoner d'elle-même elle est
revenue qu'à l'heure actuelle pour rien
de vous racketter la communauté de
pardailhan regardez comme quelques mois
suffisent pour transformer les gens au
point même qu'il est difficile de se
rappeler qu'on est en france qui
reconnaîtrait un noeud des parisiens du
11e arrondissement
ils vont planter du blé noir au
printemps et commencé l'élevage des
brebis
ils n'imaginent plus leur vie autrement
désormais c'est ce que nous ont dit
alain et claude les premiers fiancée de
la communauté oui nous pensons passer
notre vie au kibboutz et nous avons
d'autres colonies ailleurs peut-être on
ira passer s'établir dans d'autres qui
boot mais on changera pas de vivre c'est
ça qui vous plaît chloé aventure la vie
nouvelle
mais si elle pas eu cette cette histoire
du kibboutz qui date de deux ans après
tout c'est pas tellement vieux qu'est ce
que vous vouliez faire dans la vie moi
j'étais mécanicien aviation ça s'est
fini aviation maintenant annoncée
terminer sans regrets à son regret le
bonne chance merci il est monsieur
il a été promu second au concours
détracteurs de saint chinian être
content d'être en plein air de donner
les coups de hache de diriger un
tracteur c'est peut-être retrouver le
sens de la vie et du travail un peu de
frais c'était moigne et peut-être d'une
certaine naïveté mais on peut se
demander aussi ce que la société la
nôtre avait alors proposé à la place de
mieux en tout cas il est vain de leur
demander s'ils sont heureux
depuis un an c'est une question qui ne
se pose plus ils ont décidé qu'ils
l'étaient
[Musique]